true people that journal
i believe all think it will be read one
day when they're famous yeah no one
journals us if it's not going to be
ready i'm going to fight with my father
it'll be like i'm kicking him out of
your exhibit like that's what i like
that is what in it scares him i actually
think it upsets him
but it's just gonna happen i don't know
what to tell you it's not like it's
100
it's not about
if it's about when and i mean that's
like
it is weird to go through life like that
but i always used to oh my god this is
so weird i was alone so much as a kid
and i used to pretend i was always on
camera
and it's a weird thing yeah to think
about but i remember being like
and and it was a weird like maybe some
kind of survival because i always
behaved better because i was like well
i'm on camera
it was a weird thing i know and i don't
know why i just was like i also used to
like
when i was alone i would only eat like
as if i was in a commercial
i used to do that too like i would roll
up i would read like the box i would
roll up like if i was eating like um
cold cuts i'd roll them up and like eat
them the way i saw them in the oscar
mayer commercial like to probably not
eat like how they do in tv shows which
is like barely any yes totally i always
i mean it was obviously my way of
disassociating but i always like if i
was a thanksgiving or something i always
was like
eating as if i was acting
yeah you're fucking insane
yeah i did so much weird stuff like that
i mean i would think i was in music
videos like stuff like that but i also
would like
if i was like alone walking down a
hallway i was like
walking down the hallway
like
oh
on the playground in elementary school i
was like always in like a musical i was
in like hairspray or something like the
way that i was i'd be like walking and
dancing and like climbing the monkey
bars like i was in a musical i was like
in a scene in glee and then someone
would like punch me and then be kicked
out so i was in a scene in glee
and that's what happened then i was in
the glee so maybe i was just manifesting
yeah
but also like um if i was like walking
home i like i also would be in like
horror movies like i like go behind a
tree and like see that would scare me
because i i scare myself i was in a
horror movie class like this past winter
and they went around the room
and asked everyone what their biggest
fear was and someone was like break-ins
another person was like kidnapping and
like they were saying like real rational
things and then they got to me and i was
just like myself
and my professor was truly
concerned and he was like are you well
and i was like is no one else scared of
themselves i am my biggest fear like
what what like i'm i know that i'm like
the most destructive person
in my circle like i could destroy myself
with just the blink of a button do you
ever think that if you're like i don't
know
on live television or something it's
like you could just say one thing awful
in your entire career
yeah yeah right but it's like you almost
it's like standing over the edge of a
cliff and just wanting to jump you know
what it is it's which i do uh which
so
i love babies i think they're awesome um
really hot takes hot i mean i'm just
saying this is uh i just
sometimes when i'm holding a baby i'm
like what if i just drop this baby
that's a common intrusive thought oh i
actually think about all the time too
but i'm like i'm throwing just
like pushing someone off the subway
platform like yeah stuff like that where
i'm like i could literally just crack
like
stylish was telling me that not my
hairstylist i don't no one come from
actual size but this girl who was doing
my hair in near my school
she was like i was on a walk with my
baby and my baby was crying and i just
and there was a tented house and she was
like just kind of wanted to walk right
into that tented house and see what
happened
and i was like are you okay
she wasn't okay uh-huh no so she's dead
now
i'm just kidding
i used to go um into grocery stores
and um by the way biggest i'm afraid of
grocery stores they scare me
let's get to that but please continue um
uh they
i love them
uh i love them i love grocery stores and
i had such a scarcity comp like i just
love you know what it is i love that i
can afford anything in there
i think that's the main thing with
grocery stores it's like i i'm not
because i have such fucked up shit with
like
deading and buying and anytime i buy
someone i buy clothes or anything or
something nice i feel instant regret and
i'm the same with that way but with food
i'm like i know this is a good purchase
like anything i buy in this store isn't
like i'm not a piece of shit that's
overspending and like you know what i'm
saying like i am i'm not going to have
shame after this
but i used to go into grocery grocery
stores and go to like the entines like
cake section and walk by and like punch
the cakes like the top down onto the
cakes you are evil
how old were you
you're like this is last week
one point
[Music]